Don't shout at me.
So can please tell me?
I'm not going to.
Please wait.
You know, I've covered a lot of companies.
I've covered a lot of
Machiavellian companies
where, you know, people play rough.
I don't think I've ever seen anything
on the scale of Nissan.
- He is making you, but you act for Nissan.
I mean, it's corrupt.
One of the most dramatic elements
was Ravinder Passi's home being raided
by court officials in Yokohama.
- You scared my wife,
you scared my children.
I worked at Nissan for 16 years.
So Rav Passi's journey
into the darkest recesses
of the Japanese corporate world
started when he was the general counsel,
the highest corporate lawyer
position in the company.
- [Reporter] In the past few minutes,
Nissan has revealed
that its chairman has been arrested
after allegations of serious misconduct.
He was tasked with
investigating Carlos Ghosn.
And he was told, conduct
an internal investigation
and get to the heart of the matter.
And then along the way
he started to notice
serious conflicts of interest.
He is one of the few people who knows
an extreme amount of detail
regarding the alleged
crimes by Carlos Ghosn.
And he's now ready to tell
his own story on the record
about some of the events that happened.
My name's Ravinder Passi.
I'm the former global general counsel
of Nissan Motor Co. Limited.
And you could say yes,
I had a front row seat
in terms of what was going on.
- [Reporter] When Carlos Ghosn saved Nissan years ago
he was depicted in Japanese
comic books as this hero.
And now maybe we'll see comic
books where he's the villain.
In corporate Japan, Nissan
was quite an unusual company.
It was led for two decades
by a non-Japanese executive.
Well, Carlos Ghosn was a hero
in the Japanese business world.
If you had a global business celebrity
in Japan and worldwide, it
was definitely Carlos Ghosn.
- [Reporter] In a country with few foreigners
at the top, he stood out.
But over the years he saved
Nissan from bankruptcy,
allied with Renault and Mitsubishi,
and turn the alliance into one
of the most competitive in the world.
Yet as the years went on,
I think his ambitions
changed a little bit.
He started thinking about legacy plays.
And one of them was to
really tighten the alliance
between Renault and Japan.
And unbeknownst to him,
there was a contingent
of senior Nissan executives
that were really felt
threatened by that move.
They really thought that they would
lose complete control of the car company.
And even in the government
there was probably a little bit of anxiety
about a national champion
in the auto industry
falling under full-blown foreign control.
- [Reporter] Carlos Ghosn was an auto industry leader
respected by many in Japan.
Now he's in jail.
The arrest of Carlos Ghosn
came completely out of the blue.
This was in November of 2018.
He was coming to Japan
on Nissan's corporate jet
for a regular executive meeting.
And he was met on the tarmac
by Japanese authorities
who whisked him away to jail
and charged him with
financial misconduct crimes.
So what happened was that
a power struggle ensued inside the company
and somewhere along the
way it was criminalized.
By that I mean that there were allegations
leveled at Carlos Ghosn about the way
he reported his pay to
Japanese authorities,
the way he handled money
inside the company,
that in other contexts
might've been a board action,
might've been handled internally.
A number of executives at Nissan decided
to take this difference
and take it over to the
Tokyo Prosecutor's Office.
And that unleashed a chain of events
that would shake the entire auto industry.
So after Carlos Ghosn was arrested,
Nissan launched an internal investigation
into the events that led up to his arrest.
So Rav Passi is tasked with
investigating Carlos Ghosn.
And he was told, get to
the heart of the matter.
Find out what Carlos Ghosn did wrong
and bring it to our shareholders.
Yeah, it's really complicated
because you had various things
coming out of the weeds.
2018, investigation has started
and we become aware of
matters in terms of conflicts,
actions by certain individuals
that caused some concern
because things might not
quite be what they seem.
So in our story we
really took a close look
at Hari Nada and his role
in Carlos Ghosn's downfall.
Hari Nada is one of the most
fascinating figures inside Nissan.
He's also a lawyer.
He's originally Malaysian.
Hello, Mr. Hari.
And he had a meteoric
rise through the company
and became very, very close
to Carlos Ghosn and other top figures.
He had a front row seat at all
the major strategic
deliberations at the company.
And when he discovered that Carlos Ghosn,
as his final legacy play,
was going to tighten the relationship
between Renault and Nissan,
he made a decision to
go against Carlos Ghosn.
And he became one of the key figures
that decided that Carlos Ghosn had to go.
Hari Nada was somebody who actually
recruited me into the company.
So I have a long-standing
relationship with him,
or did have a long-standing
for many, many years
he was a mentor.
I had doubts about the credibility
of the process right at the start.
Hari Nada had a plea deal
with the Tokyo prosecutors.
Now that suggests he was
intrinsically involved
in some of the wrongdoing, or
the allegations of wrongdoing.
And it just didn't smell
right, just doesn't sit right.
So there was a basic conflict of interest.
In other words, Hari Nada
had to deliver results
to Japanese prosecutors to avoid
his own criminal liability,
and he's accusing and leading
the investigation of Carlos Ghosn.
Some of the people who had been involved
in the original alleged crimes
were also looking into
the affairs themselves.
Ravinder Passi began pointing out
some of these conflict of interest issues.
And the reason for that is essentially
his concern was for the company.
If the company's own
investigation into itself
was compromised, that could lead
to a very weak position
in various lawsuits
that it was dealing with across the world.
I had discussions with Hari,
discussions with the statutory auditors
about these conflicts, discussions with HR
about some of these conflicts,
because at that point
we reported into him.
You know at the time everything was quite,
as you can imagine, it
was, we've got to do this,
we've got to do that,
we've got to move fast.
But when you step back and
look at some of these things
you just think, "Oh my God,
what was going on here?"
Because me, members of my team
were being placed in immediate danger.
Your chairman's been arrested,
a representative director's been arrested.
They both happened to be foreigners.
And then now what we need to do,
we're being instructed to do,
is certain compliance professionals
need to go into properties in Brazil,
for example, and retrieve evidence.
They've got to do it very carefully,
because if they don't do it carefully
they're going to get convicted
of criminal activities.
And likewise, when a team of lawyers
were commissioned to go to Lebanon,
I mean, one of my immediate concerns was,
why are lawyers from Nissan being sent
to go to Lebanon to retrieve evidence?
These are just lawyers,
they're corporate lawyers from Nissan.
You had revelations that
a number of executives
had benefited from share
appreciation rights
when they shouldn't have.
I mean, you know,
substantive amounts of money
being taken by these guys
when they weren't entitled to take them.
And you do think, yes, how is
this going to look later on?
It's going to look quite concerning.
So that triggered for me the
sort of assessment that well,
I'm going to have to do something.
Because up until this point
I haven't put down on paper
these conflicts and these issues.
So Rav Passi makes a fateful move.
He writes this letter to the board
listing every suspicion
he has in great detail,
backed up by evidence, backed up by memos,
of why this internal investigation
had serious problems.
He sends the letter to the
board, and it's crickets.
He doesn't hear much of anything.
Nothing happened
thereafter, nothing at all.
Just like it just gone into a black box.
And he began to suspect
that there was a desire
even at the highest level within Nissan
to kind of sweep these conflicts
of interest under the rug.
Unfortunately for me, I
think, again with hindsight,
people must've thought
that this is the nail
that's sticking out
and we can't have this.
Within three days of me submitting that
to the board of directors,
that letter to the independent
board of directors,
I was removed from the Ghosn
executive conduct matters.
I was then told that I could not
attend board meetings anymore.
And up until that point
I had attended every single board meeting.
I was then also told
that after eight years
of being in Japan, I'd
be going back to the U.----K.
It eventually transpired that I'd be
the VP of projects and transformation,
managing a team of three.
So you can imagine what this
feels like at this stage,
almost an arbitrary removal from Japan
where I've lived for eight
years, had three children there,
my family has grown up, and
we've been settled there,
having a few months earlier been promoted
to vice president at the global level
to being almost demoted.
So Passi was essentially being reassigned
to get him as far away
from the internal
investigation as possible,
and also to a certain
extent in retaliation
to some of the issues that
he brought up regarding
the internal investigation and Hari Nada.
What happened to Rav Passi can be seen
as a series of corporate humiliations.
I mean, first of all, his
immediate responsibilities
were taken away from him.
Eventually he'd lost the
coveted general counsel title.
But it didn't stop there.
Toward the end of his stay in Japan,
Rav and his wife were convinced
that they were being followed.
During that period I'd noticed
that whilst driving my car
I'd have other cars following me.
First time I noticed this
was at around mid-March,
and I was driving, I can't
remember where I was going,
but this gray van, small van
just literally started following me.
And I noticed that there was somebody
in the car taking pictures.
And lo and behold, we were
absolutely being followed
either by people on foot
or other individuals,
two or three, normally
two, burly men in a car,
different cars at different
times, following us around.
They were following the family as well.
And, you know, given we'd seen,
or I'd seen the Nissan security department
behave in a very, very
egregious manner with others
in terms of following and surveilling,
I was very concerned as
to what they were doing
and who they were giving
this information to.
Because if they're giving this information
to the authorities, you do think, why?
What's going on here?
I mean, this is just not normal behavior.
And this all culminated
in a rather dramatic event
in the middle of 2020.
Who are you people?
Where Nissan had hired a legal team
and had obtained an unusual court order
from the district court in Yokohama.
To basically do a search of his home
and seizure of his, you know,
corporate laptop and phone,
and other document.
- If you don't let us in now,
we have to break this key.
So it was a pretty extreme
way to treat someone
who had spent 16 years at the company.
There's someone else at our door.
These people have all come in.
We don't really know who they are
apart from the fact that
I've been shown a badge
that says the Yokohama Court,
and they're here to recover a
laptop and the mobile phone.
It was even more weird
because I'd highlighted to the directors
that certain Nissan executives
were trying to recover
this laptop and this phone
whilst I was still in Japan.
And I was very concerned
because it had evidence on there
that related to misconduct matters
and other forms of inappropriate conduct.
It was just an another
form of intimidation,
another form of harassment
forcing me almost to leave
the company and the country.
Because once they'd retained
and obtained these items,
we were still followed.
Which again, I just couldn't understand.
What is the point of doing that?
You know, this is a car company.
This is not the KGB.
I think it's fair to say that Rav Passi
didn't have full battlefield awareness
of all the intrigue going on at Nissan.
I mean, Hari Nada is interesting
because he's both
charismatic and charming,
and one of the most brutal
corporate in-fighters
one could ever run across.
This a confidential company email, right?
You should not have this.
If he had fallen into line,
he would probably still
have his job at Nissan,
be paid very well, and continued his work.
A career that he spent 16
years building at Nissan
is irretrievably broken.
It's been smashed to smithereens.
He and his family paid
a huge price, certainly.
But in terms of being
able to sleep at night,
I think he's come out ahead.
I highlighted issues to the
highest levels of the company
so that they could be
dealt with appropriately
by those in charge.
There was no response to those.
And there was retaliation against me.
What's really profound,
absolutely profound,
is that none of your colleagues, I mean,
people you have known
for years, forget it.
Yeah.
You're on your own.
And yeah, you gotta be ready for that.
You've gotta be ready for that.
If you take it on anyway.